SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[DING]
CHOIR: [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
SPEAKER 1: [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
[ORGAN MUSIC]
CHOIR: [NON-ENGLISH SINGING]
(SINGING) [INAUDIBLE]
[ORGAN MUSIC]
(SINGING) Glory to
God in the highest!
Glory to God in the highest!
Glory, glory, glory.
[ORGAN MUSIC]
Blessed be his holiness.
Blessed be [INAUDIBLE].
Praise him.
[ORGAN MUSIC]
Blessed be his holiness.
Blessed be [INAUDIBLE].
Praise him.
Oh, [INAUDIBLE]
[ORGAN MUSIC]
SPEAKER 2: Please join me
in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance--
AUDIENCE: --to the flag of
the United States of America.
And to the republic,
for which it stands,
one nation, under God,
indivisible, with liberty
and justice for all.
SPEAKER 3: Oh God,
make speed to save us.
AUDIENCE: Oh Lord
make haste to help us.
SPEAKER 3: Glory be to
the Father and to the Son
and to the Holy Spirit--
AUDIENCE: --as it
was in the beginning,
is now, and ever shall be,
world without end, Amen.
SPEAKER 3: Praise the Lord.
AUDIENCE: The Lord's
name be praised.
SPEAKER 4: A reading
of the 19th Psalm.
"The heavens declare
the glory of God.
And the firmament
shows his handiwork.
One day speaks to another.
And one night gives
knowledge to another.
There is neither
speech nor language.
And their voices are not heard.
But their sound has gone
out into all the lands
and their words to
the end of the world.
In them, he has set a
tent for the sun, which
comes forth as a bridegroom
out of his chamber and rejoices
like a strong man
to run his course.
It goes forth from the uttermost
parts of the heavens and runs
about to the end of it again.
And there is nothing
hidden from its heat.
The law of the Lord is
perfect, reviving the soul.
The testimony of
the Lord is sure
and gives wisdom to the simple.
The statutes of the Lord are
right and rejoice the heart.
The commandment of
the Lord is pure
and gives light to the eyes.
The fear of the Lord is
clean and endures forever.
The judgments of the Lord are
true and righteous altogether,
more to be desired
are they than gold,
even much find gold,
sweeter also than honey,
than the drippings
from the honeycomb.
Moreover, by them is
your servant taught.
And in keeping them,
there is great reward.
Who can tell how
often he offends?
O cleanse me from
my secret faults.
Keep your servant also from
presumptuous ends, lest they
get the dominion over me.
So shall I be undefiled, an
innocent of great offense.
Let the words of my mouth and
the meditation of my heart
be always acceptable in
your sight, O Lord, my rock
and my redeemer."
Glory be to the
Father and to the Son
and to the Holy Spirit, as
it was in the beginning,
is now, and ever shall be,
world without end, Amen.
SPEAKER 5: Here
begins the 11th verse
of the second chapter of St.
Paul's letter to the Ephesians.
"Therefore, remember
that at one time
you Gentiles in the flesh called
'the uncircumcision' by what
is called the circumcision,
which is made in the flesh
by hands.
Remember that you
were at that time
separated from Christ,
alienated from the commonwealth
of Israel, and strangers the
covenants of promise, having
no hope and without
God in the world.
But now, in Christ Jesus,
you who once were far off
have been brought nearby
the blood of Christ.
For He himself is our peace,
who has made us both one
and has broken down in his flesh
the dividing wall of hostility
by abolishing the law of
commandments expressed
in ordinances that He
might create in himself one
new man in place of the
two, so making peace,
and might reconcile
us both to God and one
body through the cross,
thereby killing the hostility.
And he came.
And He preached peace to
you were far off and peace
to those who were near.
For through Him,
we both have access
in one spirit to the Father.
So then you are no longer
strangers and aliens,
but you are fellow citizens
with the saints and members
of the household of God.
Built on the foundation of
the apostles and prophets,
Christ Jesus himself
being the cornerstone
in whom the whole structure,
being joined together,
grows into a holy
temple in the Lord.
In Him you also are being
built together into a dwelling
place for God by the spirit."
Here ends the lesson.
CHOIR: (SINGING) [INAUDIBLE]
LARRY ARNN: The Psalmist
writes, "Unless the Lord
builds the house, those who
build it labor in vain."
A lesser authority,
but still an authority,
Winston Churchill writes,
"We shape our buildings.
And afterwards, they shape us."
We have cause to think that this
is the largest classical chapel
built in 70 years.
It's hard to prove a negative,
but the one we can find
is the Marsh Chapel at
Boston University, which
was begun in 1920 and
finished in 1950, 70 years.
The question is not
why we built this.
Does it call out to you?
When you walk in here,
don't you look up and think
of the ultimate things?
The answer to that
question is obvious.
The hard question is,
why have others not?
It's not expense.
More expensive buildings--
this is an expensive building--
more expensive buildings than
this are built every year
on college campuses.
It's not lack of example.
Any old college
campus, or almost any,
has buildings like
this to look at.
Why do they not emulate them?
That would need to be some
powerful cause, something
to obstruct that.
I think it is the
most powerful cause.
I think it is a turning away
from things that are beautiful,
which means necessarily then
also things that are true
and things that are good.
When the truth and the
beauty and good are gone,
then, of course all
reasons that demand
we strive to become good
human beings are gone.
And those reasons, disappear the
justification and requirement
for human freedom.
Also go all the
precepts that guide us
to the use of our freedom
towards civilization.
It is as if a plague
has come over the land
and that plague has
destroyed many colleges.
And if it proceeds
to its culmination,
it will destroy this one too.
But that will not happen.
We can't really today explain
all of that that I just said.
It is actually the purpose of
the activity of the college
to explain and
understand all that.
And that activity goes on
intensely now for 175 years.
What we can do is say
what caused this building.
It was caused by several things.
It is made of matter, stone and
steel, plaster and wood, glass,
and granite.
The marble in 12
varieties comes from--
and some rose onyx--
comes from Carrera
in Italy where
they are quarrying to repair
the cathedral of Milan.
The limestone is from
quarries in Indiana
that supplied most of
the limestone that's
in the nation's capital, in
those great old classical
buildings.
The granite come from Georgia,
Vermont, and Missouri.
The silver cloud granite
on the fountain outside
comes from India.
The brass cross up
here is from Spain.
We like to publish
that old essay
by Leonard Read, "I, a Pencil."
And that's the
strongest demonstration
I've ever read of the utter
power of the free market.
Because, actually,
this building has
been produced by the
cooperation of people
all over the world who
don't know each other,
often didn't know what
they were contributing to.
This building has
been built by people.
Begin with the
designer, the architect.
Aristotle speaks of art
that are architectonic.
It comes from the
combination of arca--
beginning or rule or principle--
and techne, art.
It's the art that commands.
It organizes all
the things under it.
Abstracted from
its chief meaning
in the design of buildings,
it just means ruling, art.
Our architect is
and is understood
to be one of the
best in the world.
He is Duncan Stroik.
He was assisted
mostly by many people,
but mostly by Tom Stroka
and Jamie LaCourt.
His credentials are sterling.
He went to Yale and Harvard.
No, he went to--
where'd you go?
Where did he go?
It doesn't matter where he went.
He went to Virginia and Yale.
He says his teachers are
Thomas Jefferson and others.
But his direct teacher
was Allan Greenberg
who's one of the
midwives the revival
of classical architecture in
our time, a very great man.
Duncan can stand
for all the artisans
who've worked on this
because he's the first
and he commanded the others.
I'd like Duncan and his
colleagues to stand up, please.
[APPLAUSE]
That caused me to look up.
And it leads me to remind you
kids sitting on the front row,
don't fall off.
Duncan and I are
having an argument
about whether those
rails are too low.
So far he wins.
The fountain outside was
designed by another architect.
Her name is Alice Arnn.
And she might stand up, please.
[APPLAUSE]
I happen to know that girl.
And she will not like it
that I made her stand up.
And she really
would not like if I
didn't mention that Duncan
Stroik helped her a lot.
The builders built
this building.
They're Weigand Construction.
They work for us a lot.
They're awesome.
They're losing money on this.
They would be one of the
biggest contributors to this.
They estimated, with their
usual precision and skill--
but nobody's done
this in living memory,
there's no one alive
who's done this.
And so they got
some things wrong.
And those happen
to be things that
are in their responsibility.
They told us about it.
They asked us not
to tell the workmen
because they didn't want the
workmen to change anything.
Then they mentioned
that maybe they'd
hope to work for the
college again sometime.
And we told them that that
would have happened anyway.
The workmen on the
building, we're
going to have a convocation
soon in here for the college.
And we're going to
invite all the workmen.
And we're going to put a plaque
up, put their names on it here.
And I will tell you that
they work into the night.
Mark, the supervisor,
told me that he'd not
been to his beloved
lake for two years.
There were 60 people working
here on Tuesday of this week.
And I never see them stop work.
Except I come in
and they come to see
me and they want to
show me something.
And they thank me
for the privilege
of helping to build this.
They made this building.
My colleagues have made this
building, working together
for 20 years now,
which Pewe has taken
the lead in doing all of this.
And so, of course,
it's his responsibility
that the east arcade
is not quite finished.
[LAUGHTER]
John Sweeney's hand is in
everything here on the campus.
The way we work together,
David Whalen, Diane Philipp,
Mike Harner, several others,
we sat for hours with Duncan.
They were delightful hours too.
Duncan is very quick and
intelligent and also stubborn.
And the plan emerged
from those meetings.
And the building would be
different without them.
All of you built this building.
Begin with Jack and Jo Babbitt.
Jo said to me in an providential
and embarrassing thing,
she saw that little chapel that
she calls a wine cellar now
that was serving
as a chapel here.
The college has always
had a chapel, by the way.
There used to be one up in
the top of Central Hall.
It was quite pretty back then.
And we built the College
Baptist Church in the 1870s.
But we didn't have any
chapel on the campus,
except that little thing.
And she just thought
that was terrible.
And she said, "Why don't
you have a proper chapel?"
And I said, "Well,
I've been waiting.
We have a plan for one."
We made a plan for
the campus in 2001
and there's a
chapel on the plan.
And I said, "I've been
waiting for somebody to say,
'you need an excellent chapel,
I would like to help you build
that.'"
And she repeated those
words back to me.
Think of what that means.
Her name is back there.
We had to fight to
get that and Jack's.
But Christ Chapel,
she wanted it to be
called, which is, of course,
exactly the right thing.
Jack and Jo, stand up please.
[APPLAUSE]
You'll see some other names on
one of the plaques out there.
There's not that many
recognitions in this building.
Most people didn't want it.
But Bill Atherton and his
family are right there.
And people have been
so generous, you know?
And why do they do that?
Same reason we do
what we do here.
That makes, by the
way, all of you,
that makes everyone who will see
the ceremony, everyone who will
take joy from this chapel--
and that will be millions--
it means that they
are here today.
And they are among the
builders of this building.
The faculty and the
students are crucial because
without the activities
that they carry on,
I argue better than
anywhere on Earth,
how would anybody
think that it was
even plausible that we could
have a building like this?
And yet, because of them
and their work, they fit.
I thank you all.
Even those kids up there, who
I do hope they don't fall off,
but if they do, we can get more.
[LAUGHTER]
This building has a form.
It is classical.
What does that mean?
Does that mean that it
looks Greek or Roman?
It turns out that the innovation
of the Greeks and the Romans
was to look beyond
their own things
to the things that are
right, whatever their source
or place of origin.
That's not what it means.
Unlike Duncan Stroik
and my daughter,
I've actually paid tuition
at an architecture school.
And I feel entitled to
speak on the subject.
[LAUGHTER]
Classical architecture,
I've teased it out of them.
They don't, by the way, they're
reticent about revealing
their secrets.
They want you to think it's all
just a mystery, because it is.
But they're like--
especially Alice,
she's much worse than Duncan.
It has to fit in its place.
It has to go with the
things that are around it.
We have a beautiful building
right over there, 1852.
Some of the most important
things in American history
have happened in there.
Frederick Douglass
spoke in there.
The building points up.
The ceilings are high.
The windows are generous,
arched at the top like this.
This has to fit with that.
One of Duncan's
inventions, because he
knew all that in a heartbeat.
In fact, he showed us pictures
of some of the new buildings
because he didn't know--
either he's more artful
even than I think
or he didn't know
that they were new.
And he said, boy, people
who planned this college,
they really thought hard about
how to make it work altogether.
You have to live up to
that responsibility.
And later Whalen pointed
out to him, I think,
that he was talking
about two buildings that
were six years old.
We were a little
cocky about that.
But it has two towers.
Because if it just
had one, it would
have to be much higher
than Central Hall.
And that would not be right.
So although it's much
larger than Central Hall,
it fits here in its place.
The materials have to work.
This is a yellow brick,
the old thing here.
I confess, I did have a woman
say to me one time looking
at Strosacker Hall
after we remodeled
it, she said, "Dr. Arnn,
is that a green building?"
And I said, "No, ma'am.
That building is yellow."
[LAUGHTER]
That lady was a donor.
I don't know if she still is.
It means more than
proportion even.
It means it's right, whatever it
is that takes to make it right.
It has to be like that.
It's a classical building.
It's like what the Greeks did.
A blessing to all of us, we
study that here, of course.
I have one more cause
to name, but I'll
name it at the moment we
dedicate the building.
Right now, I will say that
the ceremony would not
be right if there were not
the right kind of speaker.
I don't know that
I know another.
We were talking about
how we would do this.
And I said, you
know, the college
stands for these four things.
We're going to need somebody who
represents these four things.
Somebody has to
have a character--
self-effacing,
courageous, assertive.
Somebody has to have learning.
Do you know what
he's accomplishing?
It's breathtaking.
I knew him before
he got on the court.
And I once thanked him for this.
Because what he's doing is, in
the ordinary doing of his work,
in his joining in verdicts and
his explaining his opinion,
he is writing an accurate
constitutional history
of the United States.
And he's showing a way
out of the distortions
that have come upon us for
the last three generations.
It is breathtaking.
If you doubt it, read three
opinions, my favorite,
US versus Lopez, Missouri
versus Jenkins, and the recent,
McDonald versus Chicago.
And they show the
way to fix all this
so far as the court can fix it.
A learned man, it
would have to be
a man who loves freedom and
the American constitutional
republic.
This man is the greatest living
interpreter of those things.
And finally, it would have to
be a man of faith, somebody who
bows in humility before God.
Think of those things together.
Who would be like that?
Clarence Thomas.
[APPLAUSE]
CLARENCE THOMAS: Thank you.
Thank you.
I feel like quitting
while I'm ahead.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you, Dr. Arnn.
And thank you for
inviting my wife and me
to Hillsdale once again.
It seems like homecoming,
we've been here so often.
The campus is magnificent.
I'm honored to have
this task of speaking
to you all this afternoon--
or this morning.
But I wondered as
Dr. Arnn was speaking
whether I'm up to that task.
And I pray that I am.
This is a very special occasion.
It's the 175th
anniversary of Hillsdale
and the dedication of
this beautiful chapel.
Christ Chapel is a culmination
of years of generosity,
planning, and hard work.
And the end result is at
once stunning and glorious.
The chapel's enduring beauty
highlights the transcendence,
the sovereignty, and
the grace of God.
It truly illustrates
how architectural design
can reflect the character of God
and evoke a sense of reverence
for his majesty.
Everyone involved in
the financing, planning,
and the construction of this
chapel should rightly be proud.
It is a magnificent
accomplishment.
But we have gathered
here today not just
to admire this beautiful chapel.
We are also here to dedicate it.
The word dedicate
in this context
means to set apart and
consecrate to a deity
or to a sacred purpose.
To appropriately dedicate
this chapel then,
it is worthwhile to reflect
on the purposes for which we
are here, we are setting
apart this sacred place
on a college campus.
The primary purpose
of a chapel is
to provide a place where man
can enter the presence of God.
It provides a
sanctuary in which man
can withdraw from the
chaos of our world
and seek a sacred stillness.
For as Elijah learned
on Mount Horeb,
God so often comes to
us not in the storms,
not in the earthquakes or fires
of life, but in stillness,
in a gentle whisper.
Accordingly, men and women
have long sought respite
from the noise and
commotion of daily life,
where they can be
still and know that he
is God, where they
can seek an inner calm
and a transcendent peace.
Beautiful chapels
such as this one
provide that sacred
space for stillness,
a place for an encounter
with the divine.
As the architect
of this chapel has
written, when you
enter a church,
it is as if you are
entering through a gateway
from the profane
toward the sacred.
It is difficult to overstate
the significance of the role
that this particular chapel will
play in the life of Hillsdale
College.
Many of life's momentous
events take place in chapels.
Take weddings for example.
When a couple enters into the
sacred covenant of marriage,
they do so not only
before friends and family,
but also before almighty God.
When the wedding is
held in the chapel,
the chapel exalts the
occasion and signifies
that God himself is a witness to
the couples' exchange of vows.
Or reflect on funerals
and memorial services.
As we grieve the loss of a
friend or a family member
and reflect on
their lives, we also
seek comfort, hope, and peace.
Conducting that solemn
service in a chapel
reminds us that
our deepest needs
are met through God, who is
near to the brokenhearted,
the wretched, and the lonely.
And as we are drawn to
reflect on that eternal life
beyond the grave, a sacred
space, such as this chapel,
with an image of the cross,
that old rugged cross,
serves as a poignant
testament to the hope
of the resurrection.
Chapels also provide a space
for other important activities
that take place on a
more regular basis.
For example, worship services
will be held in this chapel.
If our highest purpose
is to glorify God,
what better resource to
provide on a college campus
than a chapel that
allows students, faculty,
administrators, staff, and
visitors to gather together
for worship and prayer?
This chapel also will serve
as a setting for ceremonies
and liturgical
concerts, allowing
all who gather here to
learn together and celebrate
before God.
And the chapel will
be used regularly
for personal prayers of
reflection, meditation,
confession, repentance,
forgiveness,
and reconciliation.
Chapels are particularly
important in providing a place
for the burdened, for the
brokenhearted and despairing.
When life is difficult
and seems pointless,
we need a safe haven where
we can escape from the storm
and find solace.
Chapels provide that setting.
They invite us to
draw near to God
and to elevate our thoughts,
to seek his wisdom,
to lay down our burdens
at the foot of the cross,
and to find that peace that
surpasses all understanding.
For here we know we are
standing on holy ground.
In the words of a
popular gospel hymn,
"When I walk through the
door, I sense His presence.
And I knew this place, this
was a place where love abounds,
for this is a temple.
The God we love abides here.
Oh, we are standing in the
presence, his presence,
on holy ground."
This calls to mind Hannah, the
mother of the prophet Samuel.
When she came to the
tabernacle to pray,
she was barren but
longed for a child.
The Bible describes her
as deeply depressed,
a woman troubled
in spirit who was
experiencing great anxiety and
vexation, and weeping bitterly.
But Hannah poured out
her soul before the Lord
at the tabernacle.
And after a time of prayer
and speaking with the priests,
her face was no longer sad.
She came to the
tabernacle in anguish.
She left at peace.
Hannah's story reminds
me of a young woman
I saw some years ago in the
church I attend near the court.
As I knelt saying the
rosary after mass,
I noticed her crying, her
shoulders jerking rhythmically
as she sobbed heavily.
We happened to leave the
church at the same time.
And as we did, I asked
her if she was OK.
Her face streaked
with mascara, she
answered in a quiet,
peaceful voice, "I am now."
Whatever burden that
woman was carrying
when she entered the church,
she did not leave with it.
In the words of the
letter to the Hebrews,
she drew near to
the throne of grace.
And she did so in
a church building.
I have no doubt
that many will enter
here burdened, and like
Hannah, and the young woman,
leave unburdened and at peace.
Come to me all who labor
and are heavy laden.
I will give you rest.
I humbly offer my own
story that is similar.
Like Hannah, my life was
changed through prayer
at a time at a place of worship.
Although I was raised
Catholic and even
spent four years
in the seminary,
in my early adult years, I
became greatly disillusioned
with the church, and made the
mistake of angrily storming
away, impetuousness of youth.
Throughout law school and
the early years of my career,
I was self-reliant,
so I thought, and gave
little attention to God.
But not long after I
joined President Reagan's
administration, I
was in the midst
of one of the darkest
periods of my life.
I was in my 30s,
running a federal agency
under significant public
scrutiny and criticism.
I had little money.
I was raising my young son.
And I was grieving the loss of
the two most important people
in my life, my grandparents.
Life seemed hopeless and felt
like I had nowhere to turn.
In the midst of this
hardship and grief,
God drew me back to the church.
And he used a church
building to do it.
It was during this period
seemingly bereft of hope
that I began to
make daily visits
to local Catholic churches to
pray for wisdom and courage,
as well as strength
and guidance.
Unlike the tumultuous
world around me,
the church building provided
a place of peace, a sanctuary
from the turmoils of my life.
Within those walls, with
God's help and grace,
I was able to
elevate my thoughts
beyond my circumstances
and self-absorption,
and set my mind on
things that are above,
not on things that are on
Earth, as Saint Paul wrote
in the letter to the Galatians.
God used these times of
prayer and meditation
to rekindle the flame
of faith in my life.
I am a changed man today.
And God began that
transformation
in a holy place, a sanctuary,
which like this chapel, where
I could temporarily--
a sanctuary much
like this chapel
where I could temporarily leave
behind the onslaught of life's
difficulties and bring my
troubles before the Lord.
God used this renewed
faith to sustain me
and my wife through my
confirmation hearings.
And we continue to rely daily
on the grace he gives us.
But there is nothing unique
about this in our lives.
For many people,
chapels and churches
have served as beacons of hope,
physical reminders of our need
for God and his grace.
And the presence of a
chapel on a college campus
is particularly important.
In fact, in this age
of popular iconoclasm,
building a chapel on a college
campus is all but verboten.
The college years
require young people
to make decisions that will
affect the rest of their lives.
They are exposed to new
ideas, new relationships,
new distractions,
and new temptations.
They need a place
where they can go
to be relieved of their troubles
and get their bearing as so
much comes at them so fast.
By building this chapel,
Hillsdale College
has provided that
space where students
can come to discern
God's calling,
to pray through difficult
times, and to praise
God for his faithfulness.
In short, Hillsdale College
has recognized the importance
of equipping students not
only intellectually, but also
spiritually for the many
challenges of life in college
and beyond.
Although a chapel is a
place for many activities,
it also serves as a statement
about the importance
of those activities.
The construction of a
college chapel in particular
is a public declaration
that faith and reason
are mutually reinforcing.
And in 2019, the
construction of a chapel
is a bold act of leadership at
a crucial time in our nation's
history.
So I would like to
briefly underscore
the broader significance
of the decision
that Hillsdale College has
made in building Christ Chapel.
Beginning in the early 1900s,
many elite private colleges
and universities began
to face questions
about the continuing relevance
of religious instruction
on campus.
These questions would have
surprised the founders
of those schools, many
of which were created
in part for the expressed
purpose of providing
religious instruction.
But as time went on
and schools moved away
from their religious
roots, the relevance
of religion to higher education
was increasingly questioned.
And campus chapels
in particular came
to be viewed as relics
of a bygone era.
With the completion
of Christ Chapel,
Hillsdale College has staked
out its position in this debate.
And its decision serves as
an example for all of us.
The construction of so
grand a chapel in 2019
does not happen by accident
or as an afterthought.
Christ Chapel reflects
the college's conviction
that a vibrant
intellectual environment
and a strong democratic society
are fostered, not hindered,
by a recognition of the divine.
Hillsdale College affirms
with the writer of Proverbs
that "the fear of the Lord
is the beginning of wisdom
and the knowledge of the
Holy One is insight."
By constructing this
chapel, the college
upholds the continued importance
of its Christian roots,
even as it respects the rights
of each person to worship God
according to the dictates
of his own conscience.
Our country was
founded on the view
that a correct understanding
of the nature of God
and the human person is
critical to preserving
the liberty that we so enjoy.
John Adams wrote,
"Our constitution
was made only for a moral
and religious people.
It is wholly inadequate to
the government of any other."
He recognized that the
preservation of liberty
is not guaranteed.
Without the guardrails supplied
by religious conviction,
popular sovereignty can
devolve into mob rule, unmoored
from any conception
of objective truth.
As I think about our
political culture today,
I am reminded of Ronald
Reagan's warning,
that freedom is never more
than one generation away
from extinction.
We didn't pass it to our
children in the bloodstream.
The only way they can inherit
the freedom we have known
is if we fight for it, protect
it, defend it, and then
hand it to them to do the same.
Each generation is
responsible to both itself
and to succeeding generations
for preserving and promoting
the blessings of liberty.
Faith in God, more
than anything else,
fuels the strength of
character and self-discipline
necessary to ably discharge
that responsibility.
That is why I am so encouraged
by the construction of Christ
Chapel.
Hillsdale College's
Articles of Association
affirm that
"inestimable blessings
flow from the prevalence of
civil and religious liberty
and intelligent
piety in the land."
The college was
founded on the belief
that the diffusion
of sound blending
is essential to the
perpetuity of these blessings.
Thus, Hillsdale College was
founded on the understanding
that the battle to preserve and
promote freedom in our country
will be waged in the hearts
and minds of the people.
Rather than shrinking
from the battle,
Hillsdale is rising
to the occasion
by investing in the intellectual
and spiritual development
of its students so they can
provide God-honoring leadership
in our country.
Let it be said of
them what was said
of David, that he served
the counsel of God
in his own generation.
Students, faculty,
administrators,
and friends of Hillsdale,
let this chapel
be more than just an
impressive building.
Let it be a place
where people enter
the presence of a majestic God.
Let it be a house of worship,
of prayer, of meditation,
and of celebration before God.
Let it be a haven of
rest for the weary,
a place of healing
for the wounded,
a place of comfort for the
grieving, and a source of hope
for the despairing
and forgotten.
Let it point to a day
when the dwelling of God
will be with men, when
God himself will wipe away
every tear and mend every wound.
Let it be a place where
tomorrow's leaders discern
their callings and grow
firm in their convictions.
Let it stand as a bold
declaration to a watching world
that faith and
learning are rightly
understood as
complements and that both
are essential to
the preservation
of the blessings of liberty.
Above all, let this
chapel equip and inspire
us to honor God in
whatever he calls us to do.
For as Saint Paul wrote in
the letter to the Romans,
"From him and through him
and to him are all things.
To him be the glory
forever, Amen."
May God bless each of you.
May God bless Hillsdale.
And may God bless this
wonderful country.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]